you never said that I said it you did no
I never said you should go through a
whole phase you said date multiple guys
so I cannot say it has to be oh but we
know what I mean I think you should live
your life and see who you are so then
later on when you're ready and when
you're emotionally mature because when
you're 21 too you don't know what the
[ __ ] going on at least I didn't I mean
I moved here when I was 22. so
in this past eight nine years I changed
a lot because I learned Who I Am What if
I got married to a guy that I was dating
when I was 21 22 because my goal in life
was to get married I would I didn't know
who I am okay so how can you get married
and be with somebody
but you're not even sure who you are so
how do you guys grapple that because
you're basically saying the exact
opposite thing that she's saying so
would you guys engage and have this
conversation what that means you don't
know who you are you're trying to figure
out what you want in life like I just
I've always known who I am well not
everybody does the same
I just don't get what girls mean when
they say that I'm top G